i can't say a lot but i can say that the
scripts are done i did not write them
uh by choice this time um but
that's pretty much all i'm allowed to
even say i've already gotten my like
in red bull do not talk about the other
movies
uh but i'm excited and i'm happy for the
fans that they get
the next movies congratulations
on this movie you know seeing the fan
reaction to
after and this incredible fan base that
you've been able to build
was there added pressure going into
filming the sequel
are you in love with them
you're never gonna trust me trust you
where has that ever gotten me
yes um i mean especially because a lot
of the fans
uh as much as they went and saw after
they weren't necessarily
happy with the way it turned out so
we learned from that mistake for sure um
and uh i also agreed with them in a way
so
i get it uh but there was a little more
pressure just because we already had
all the success so when you have that
obviously there's a little more pressure
so do you think fans will be happy now
with after we collided
yes definitely and the fans in other
places that have seen it they're all
like this is exactly what we wanted so
i'm like yay
we listen to you
just be careful what happened it has to
do with heart
in this movie i feel like we dive deeper
into
hero's childhood trauma and i feel like
it's so important to show
you know his journey and even mentioning
you know his
experience with therapy and his mental
health i mean why is this journey so
important to portray
to an audience outside of just a romance
storyline
well for me it that's kind of what goes
away
when people talk about the story they
always talk about the sex or this or
that but they never talk about
the trauma the therapy the years of time
they spend apart
so for me i was so glad to be able to
talk about that because otherwise
at the end of the day you just have a
bad boy who's just
a jerk for no reason it doesn't have any
depth so a lot of times i get like
very frustrated when people don't read
the books or now
in the first movie you're like okay we
don't really understand why he is that
way
so we focused heavily on or as heavy as
we could on
him actually like he has mental health
problems and he has an addiction
and it's not just like a cute like boy
who is mean sometimes
and so now what we've seen with his
journey so far after we collided is that
kind of setting
up the stage to continue to see a
transformation in
movies three and four yeah definitely i
mean if they go
the right way then yes the idea would be
to show a full-on character art and
development for both of them but
especially for him and his addictions
yeah well speaking of movies three and
four i'm so excited for you guys and i
know that it's already been announced
that there will obviously be
number three and four are the scripts
written like what's the update with it
um i can't say a lot but i can say that
the scripts are done
i did not write them uh by choice this
time um
but that's pretty much all i'm allowed
to even say i've already gotten my like
in red bull do not talk about the other
movies
uh but i'm excited and i'm happy for the
fans that they get
the next movies i know you can't say
much about the next
you know movies three and four but has
the pandemic
kind of shifted any plans with that or
no effect uh it definitely has i mean
for me personally i can't save for the
whole production but for me it's changed
a lot um i wish that you know the people
in charge would have waited a little bit
to film because we have
a cast member who was pregnant who you
know had to be recast and
a couple other issues that came up that
you know it just for me didn't really
make sense why
they couldn't wait but that's the battle
here is the creatives versus suits
so we all know who wins that one so i
get
it um but it changed a lot but i think
we just all kind of have to get used to
this new way of filming new way of
producing new
way of everything to keep everyone safe
now will you do you think the fans will
be happy with three and four now that
you you made them happy with two
um one can help that's all we can do is
hope
one can help i mean for you personally
you know
how has it been to see this incredible
fan base
just so in love and obsessed with
this franchise it's really great i mean
before it felt like kind of our little
secret like i had a big fan base but it
wasn't
public it was all kind of living on the
internet so for now it's fun to see
it's kind of left that little ecosystem
and now it's
everywhere like i hear people randomly
talking about it i see like people from
my hometown posting about it they have
no idea that i'm even like
involved in it so it's uh funny the how
big it spread
you